wow I love finding old garden books this
is called the garden of experience by
the author of garden of ignorance and
these old garden books are so cool they
don't have pictures so they had to be
excellent garden Writers to actually
paint a picture of what it was that you
were learning the garden and creating a
garden so look at this when I found is
called a sense of humors and it is
another book written 0 60 years ago and
and the pages even the fact that they're
faded makes it just really cool to dive
into really old gardening books here's
when this called the embattled male in
the garden now hopefully it's written by
a female and even has the old seattle
public library i found these old books
at a store that specializes in antique
garden books but i also found this one
this is down the garden path now it's
written by a famous garden writer called
beverly nichols but when you read old
garden books like this it doesn't matter
there's no pictures because of the
garden tips some of the advice in this
book one thing I remember Beverly
Nichols writing about was when you water
lilies to use lukewarm water now that's
something I'd never heard before and
it's something that he learned you know
a hundred years ago growing lilies now
if you can't find old antique garden
books they've been reissuing them Timber
Press is a publisher that's reissuing
books by Beverly Nichols the old garden
writer this one is Rhapsody in green and
it's and it's kind of the best of some
of the old gardening advice that was
written so if you love history if you
love old gardens and heritage gardens
start checking out some of these old
historical garden books it's a great way
to really get down and dirty without
going outside